At work,
you are likely to move from being a manager to a leader.
Leadership and management are closely linked
since most leaders also manage teams,
projects or functions.
Explore the key differences between these 2 roles Leadership
is key to driving growth The leader looks to the future and anticipates
changes that will advance his or her business.
The manager ensures order and coherence.
He must develop a stable and coherent work environment
to optimize employee productivity.
Management emerged with the industrial revolution,
when it was necessary to organize the work of large teams,
the modern manager was born.
The roles of manager and leader sometimes present contradictions.
Think back to your last 2 weeks of work to identify when you have acted
as a manager or leader Here are some key differences The 1st is about
the and practical approach Strategic and visionary manager side,
leader side,
time frame is not the same The manager acts in the moment and sets short
and medium term goals to ensure business success.
The leader thinks about the future and defines the strategies
and changes that will shape the company of tomorrow.
If the manager focuses on internal practices,
the leader favors the outside He studies other functions,
the market,
the sector and national and international activity.
Let's take the example of Séréna who is vice-president of sales at Kinateko Kinaeko
is classified as a Fortune 500 and specializes in renewable energies.
Serena leads the sales department and oversees 4 service managers
each with 1 dedicated sales team Serena manages when hosting meetings
on quarterly sales objectives She acts as a leader when studying the
financing project for the construction of a port within 10 years and
positions her company to seize this opportunity.
The manager exploits available resources and structures,
while the leader defines new processes for the future.
Serena uses her management skills to assess an employee's performance via
the current system She becomes a leader when she proposes to transform
the company's management system and access assessments on skills
The manager's task is to manage the employees on
a daily basis to achieve the objectives set.
The leader must plan for the future,
have a long-term vision and define an evolutionary strategy.
Serena manages when analyzing the monthly results of its service,
sets new objectives and trains its teams.
She takes on her leadership role when it comes to hiring staff
abroad and forming multilingual teams to develop international sales.
Finally,
let's take an interest in skills The manager and
the leader use emotional intelligence.
The role of the former is more,
it communicates one-on-one,
delegates tasks,
stimulates employee performance The latter establishes
a culture to optimize interactions,
appeal to shareholders,
encourage collaboration and train the new generation of leaders The company's prospects
are based on optimizing its main resource,
Serena manages talents when she brings together her direct employees to assess how
they manage and lead their team She is leader in identifying high-potential employees
and involving them in cross-cutting teams to analyze market trends
In the exercise files,
indicate your management and leadership activities and
a percentage of time for each of them.
We will return to this estimate.